All right. So back to indigenous people's day or the first peoples day. Um,
so, so basically it's, there's a show.
It says in history that we learned about it to grow and move up by native
American activists and art, native Americans are all activists. I mean.
Well, no, I don't think they are left with much of an option,
but to fight for the tiny that we gave them.
That's like, I love how, like,
when people were yelling about the Cleveland Indians and the Washington
Redskins, it's like that wasn't native Americans. They don't give a. Like, no,
but that was all bunch of.
Finally became when, when enough white people were upset.
About mascots.
Native Americans were like, Oh, well, if this is the thing,
that's going to bring attention to all the up you've done.
Yes. It should have been named the Washington Karen's.
Dude. I would have loved. Could you imagine.
In their helmets just had a little blonde hair.
Just the Nancy. It's just the Nancy grace haircut on the side logo.
Oh dude, that would be great. And their fight song is called.
Can I speak to your manager? Can I speak to your
[inaudible] we're back with the Patriots down 14 to seven are the Karen's
Karen's driving the ball duty.
It's native Americans were like, Oh cool. Yeah, you guys don't like that.
They call it the Indians. We never had a chance to voice our opinion.
It was the best buy. And you're like,
did you know that that actually plot of land bullet belong to the legato?
You know? Like they were like, wow.
That's pretty up wind hundreds.
Of years ago. And they're like, no, a hundred years ago.
Yeah. Your grandmother's are don't get me started.
Yeah, because I dated one. I grew up.
He would scrape it. He would flip me around on his horse.
I dated, never calls you back. That was his name.
Marie, sorry, Mary Lou. I just felt like we didn't really hit it off.
The son told the coyote to not call. You got, gotta get out of,
not call him. I went to the river for a message,
but realized that the snake had taken my love for you.
What does that mean? Runs with storms, having sex with your sister.
It means I'm carnival over it just gotta be like.
I can get out of anything by just blaming it on the elements.
Just listen to them.
To the soul of the, of the world and you can blame it anything.
Why don't you show up and you go, Oh, I just felt like the wind, the, uh,
the soul of the wind told me to go home and take it.
Now, anytime I'm about to break up with a girl,
I just start doing meditation and yoga just so I can be like one with my spirits
to like blame it on that. Yeah.
I'm just really doing a lot of.
Inner work. Not you. It's my chakras say that it's not right.
And do you respect that now?
Any native American blood,
you can tell them that an Eagle came and saw you and brought the spirit of the
wind and I am destined for other,
But it's, it's so up because when you love Colorado and stuff, like,
it's kind of what you're saying. You have to learn the up parts.
What we're talking about, like with the,
with the native Americans and all that kind of is it's they gave them land.
Dude. I didn't think about this until recently. In fact it was,
I think what made me think of it was the last time I was on history hyenas when
I was in fifth grade in Aurora, shout out mission, Viejo elementary school,
Roadrunners, dude, getting it done.
You should be able, it's just sounds like a good burrito. It is.
I'd like to mission van burrito with extra guac.
Could you do a mission Viejo with no beans?
That's good. That's pretty good. And you go,
you guys do case that fresco on that or are you a Chihuahua cheese?
Um, but they, uh,
in fifth grade they took us to a
reservation. Wow. To see how life is on the reservation.
And there's just other ten-year-old kids there that are like.
Hey, yeah.
I remember being that live in your neighborhood that you would never meet. No,
but I'm saying like, they're not even in my neighborhood.
We went to their reservation, dude. We went to Eastern.
Colorado. Also. They do,
they don't put them in like Inglewood or Littleton.
They put them in like four East, like Sterling, like it out.
And you go out there and it's like dirty, dusty. Cause it's not,
it's not by any good land. Right.
And you're just this 10 year old kid looking at another 10 year old kid.
And he's like, Hey, you know,
like I remember they would like come up and see us and we'd be like, Hey,
you know.
We were ships to them. Oh, a Toyota child. Oh,
yellow school bus. It's not real.
But I always remember the craziest thing you ever get with an arrow. I'm like,
Oh God, come on of us. Came back without hair. We've got scalped.
Remember getting on the bus and being like, yo,
this is a field trip for us.
And we're going home. Yeah. They just live here.
Kind of went to like a zoo for humans. Exactly what I was thinking.
You want to watch them feed
[inaudible]. Yeah. But that's what looking at eats the
chicken fingers with his tools are made from mammoth bones. But.
With the Bureau of Indian affairs did, is they came in and they were like, eh,
they don't want this.
Right. You're still, they have some statutes I believe up in, in Germany have,
uh, some Nazi stuff is still up there just as a reminder, the kids be like, Hey,
that's not a part of our, we don't like that part of our history.
I'm pretty sure that if you're German,
you're aware of what went down in the thirties and forties.
Yeah. We did that. Where that you didn't know,
but that feels like a more real like, Oh man, that's so weird.
So grandpa was like a bad guy. Yeah. Pretty bad. But
Germany, Japan, South.
South Africa, they do this thing where they acknowledge they do.
America seems special in the fact that we're just like, now what? Like slavery.
And you're like, come on. Yeah. We still bring that up. And you're like,
I don't know, native Americans, we put them on reservations. And we're like,
I mean, we're really going to change it from Columbus day. I like home bus.
We can't call on Columbus. And you're like, I don't know.
Maybe get them fresh drinking water. And then we can call it Columbus day.
How about we get them some decent?
How about we just kind of help them out a little and then we can call it white
dude with pink Dick day, we could get all nuts. We can get nuts if we want to.
But the F th that's the only like woke part of me is like,
why don't we help out the people that are still going through this.
Put a part of our tax money to help them out. And that's what it should be.
But I guess it's just not.
Um, I heard like the woke his out of someone that's in their sixties where I was
like, that's crazy.
I haven't heard that a Republican or Republican woman was
like, yeah, I Patriot. Yeah. She's a true Patriot. But I would,
I would guess I'm not for sure, but I know she voted for Trump in 2016.
Think maybe she'd vote for Trump in 2020. She was like, she smokes weed.
We were smoking weed and. And she was like, yeah, I think, um, I think,
uh, blacks and native Americans should be able to get the license to sell legal
weed. Like,
I think that's what we should do is like give them the licensing to sell,
to open dispensaries and stuff. And you're like,
that's woke is because you know what?
That would go a long way.
Because I do know when I went to Yanis and I went to Germany, artistry,
tour guy told us the reason why Jews have been able to assimilate back into
German society and culture. Of course, there's always, anti-Semitism,
there's hate and racism anywhere you go against every group,
somebody doesn't like somebody for some reason.
Falling into, uh, problems that have no effect on you.
Your boy went through a big phase of eating edibles and reading up on the
Sudanese civil war. And that, uh, that'll rock ya.
It's like, it's horrible. But it's like,
there's horrible things happening all day. Every day. There's so many people,
it's just, the numbers are what they are. But they said all the jerk, not all.
One of the things that German government did is like in the 1950s,
they gave Jewish citizens money, like a little bit of money. They were like,
we know this, isn't going to solve the problems,
but here's some money kind of like reparations to just be like, we aren't sorry.
The new German government like wants you here.
And like made it very easy for them to get businesses.
And it was like apologetic, as opposed to being like, Hey,
that didn't happen the way you thought it.
But that's what you run into with American, with, especially with,
with American thought in the light, the way our, this,
the way we work is if you were to give, uh,
blacks and native Americans rights to own, dispensary's immediately,
it'd be like, well, that's not a free market. Is it then? What do you do?
I never did anything. I never owned slaves. I never took land.
Why can't I have that? I need a business. And he's like, it's,
it's the selfishness of American behavior that stops us from
doing this. Right. We're just like, Oh, I need that. What about me?
And it's like, it's the collective. We, we help out the collective.
We you'll probably be a little bit better. Yeah. I agree, dude.
But people that's some cook.
Yeah. Not on this podcast. Edit that part out. What did you say? thought.
I'm doing shows and Sturgis this Saturday and Sunday.
Meet, take the land that you want. Yeah, it. Till she's got a second place.
Yeah. That's sick guy. Makeup com. Thank you so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed the last video. Don't forget to tell your friends,
like subscribe and turn on notifications.